as men we're going to hatch all kinds of  crazy schemes and plans I know that I do  anyway and and you you need a woman  there to because she could see that  blind spot and she's going to tell you  well that's that's not going to work  whereas I think for men on the other  hand uh this is my gender stereotypical  way of looking at it is that you know I  rely on my wife to let me know when I've  got some idea some plan that's just like  utterly self-destruct and it's going to  destroy the whole family  um that lessons is the key right the  last part of the sense that it's going  to destroy the whole family because my  wife tends to think in terms of the  effect on the Family